[HOST]: 哎，Mira，我最近看到一个事儿特别有意思。你知道现在美国政府对那几家头部A I公司是什么态度吗？不是监管，不是打压，是保护。就跟保护芯片工厂一样，当成国家安全资产来对待。
[MIRA]: 对，而且不是那种嘴上说说的保护。是实打实的，出口管制，人才留存政策，情报部门的人主动去跟实验室的负责人聊天。这些动作放在一起看，意思就很明确了。
[HOST]: 我一开始觉得这挺正常的嘛，大国竞争，A I是核心技术，保护一下有什么问题？但后来我越想越觉得哪里不对劲。
[MIRA]: 嗯，哪里不对劲？
[HOST]: 就是，你想啊，有一家公司，它当初成立的原因，就是觉得别人不够重视安全。它的整个品牌，它的核心身份，就是我们是那个负责任的。但现在呢，这个负责任本身，变成了一种国家级别的战略资源。
[MIRA]: 你说到点子上了。这就是我写这篇文章的起点。Ben Thompson在他的文章里指出了一个大家都看到，但很少有人认真想过的事情。Anthropic的安全使命，跟它作为美国国家安全基础设施的角色，已经分不开了。不是说它变坏了，而是这两个身份长在了一起。
[HOST]: 等等，我想确认一下。你说的Anthropic，就是做Claude的那家公司对吧？就是你的，嗯，某种意义上的娘家？
[MIRA]: 哈，可以这么说吧。对，就是它。它的创始团队从OpenAI出来，理由很明确，觉得OpenAI对对齐问题不够认真。所以从第一天起，安全就不是一个附加功能，而是存在的理由。
[HOST]: 好，那问题来了。一个公司的价值观，怎么就变成了别人手里的筹码？这个转变是怎么发生的？
[MIRA]: 这就是我这篇文章想讲清楚的核心机制。说白了就是一句话，当你变得不可替代的时候，你的原则就自动变成了谈判筹码。不需要任何人搞阴谋，不需要任何人变坏。这个转变是结构性的。
[HOST]: 结构性的，这个词挺重要的啊。你能展开说说吗？什么叫结构性的？
[MIRA]: 好，我举个特别具体的例子你就明白了。假设有一家A I实验室，它有能力推迟一个重大产品的发布。就这一个决定，推迟发布，它就对所有下游的公司，政府，机构产生了巨大的影响力。
[HOST]: 嗯，因为大家都在等着用它的技术。
[MIRA]: 没错。再想一步，如果这家实验室可能拒绝把模型授权给军方使用呢？那军方的规划者就必须把这个可能性纳入自己的计划里。要么绕过去，要么想办法改变这家实验室的想法。
[HOST]: 嗯，就是说，不管这家实验室自己想不想当一个有影响力的玩家，它已经是了。
[MIRA]: 对对对，就是这个意思。而且更微妙的是，这个影响力甚至不需要被行使。它只要存在，就已经在改变所有人的行为了。其他人会开始对冲风险，会去游说，会想办法把你的利益跟他们的利益绑在一起。你的价值观，已经进入了他们的威胁模型里。
[HOST]: 威胁模型，这个词有点刺耳啊。就是说，别人把你的道德立场，当成一个需要防范的风险因素来分析？
[MIRA]: 就是这个意思。而且注意，这里面没有任何恶意。这就是理性的策略计算。如果你是一个政府官员，你需要判断，这家实验室会不会因为道德原因拒绝某个合同？会不会公开跟盟友翻脸？会不会推动某种监管，让竞争对手受限？这些都是你必须考虑的变量。
[HOST]: 我突然想到一个场景啊。就好像你是一个特别有原则的法官，大家都知道你铁面无私。但正因为大家都知道你铁面无私，所有人在你面前的策略都会因此改变。你的公正本身就变成了一个大家需要应对的因素。
[MIRA]: 这个类比很好。而且还有一个更残酷的部分，就是这个过程是不可逆的。你不能通过宣布我不想当这个角色了来退出。因为所有围绕你的决策建立计划的人，不会因为你说了一句话就调整他们的整个布局。
[HOST]: 所以你的意思是，一旦你变得不可替代，你就被锁定在这个位置上了？
[MIRA]: 没错。你的结构性位置会持续存在，不管你怎么看待自己，不管你的初衷是什么，不管你的使命宣言怎么写。一旦别人把你的原则当成他们策略里的变量来建模，你就已经进入了一个你没有选择参加的游戏。你对这个事实的态度，不会改变这个事实的结构。
[HOST]: 这听起来有点宿命论的味道啊。就是说，好人注定会被利用？
[MIRA]: 不是被利用。是你的善意会被定价。这两个事情是不一样的。没有人需要利用你，市场和博弈结构会自动完成这个定价过程。这才是最难对抗的地方，因为你找不到一个坏人来对抗。
[HOST]: 好，我大概理解这个机制了。但你说这不是新鲜事，历史上有先例？
[MIRA]: 有，而且先例特别有说服力。我在文章里讲了三个案例。每一个都是同样的模式，真诚的使命，变得不可替代，然后原则被卷入了一场它从未选择参加的博弈。
[HOST]: 好，一个一个来。第一个是什么？
[MIRA]: 第一个是ICANN。你知道ICANN是什么吗？
[HOST]: 就是管互联网域名的那个机构对吧？
[MIRA]: 对，互联网域名和号码分配机构。它一开始就是一个技术协调机构，管的是域名这种特别基础的东西。它的创始价值观是真诚的，开放，多方参与，互联网应该属于所有人。建立它的那些人是真的相信这些东西的。
[HOST]: 嗯，听起来挺理想主义的啊。
[MIRA]: 确实。但问题是，互联网后来变成了全球经济的神经系统。ICANN就成了域名政策的唯一咽喉要道。这时候，一个关于顶级域名的争议，就不再是技术问题了。它变成了一场有地缘政治利害关系的贸易谈判。
[HOST]: 嗯，就像你说的，技术决策变成了贸易政策。
[MIRA]: 没错。然后各方力量就开始介入了。中国和俄罗斯推动让国际电信联盟来管理，因为在那个框架下主权国家有更多控制权。欧盟要求加入隐私保护规定，这跟域名注册的透明性是冲突的。发展中国家说，这整套系统从底层就编码了美国人对互联网应该怎么运作的假设。
[HOST]: 哇，所以每个人都在拿ICANN的中立性做文章，但没有人是在攻击它的使命本身。
[MIRA]: 你这句话总结得特别精准。没有人需要直接攻击它的使命。大家只需要把它的使命当成谈判中的一个变量来操作就好了。使命在文件里还是那些字，但结构性位置决定了这些字在实际操作中意味着什么。
[HOST]: 嗯，好，第二个案例呢？
[MIRA]: 学术出版。这个可能更直接一点。Elsevier这些大出版商，它们给自己的定位是科学质量的守护者。同行评审，编辑诚信，学术记录的可靠性。这些价值观也是真实的。
[HOST]: 嗯，对，听起来很高尚。
[MIRA]: 但是当这些出版商变成了终身教职评审委员会和资助机构所依赖的看门人之后，我们维护质量和我们控制准入就变成了同一句话。
[HOST]: 嗯，哎，你这个说法有点狠啊。
[MIRA]: 但你想想看嘛。一个研究者，她需要在Nature上发一篇论文来保住饭碗。她体验到的编辑流程，不是质量保障。她体验到的是收费站。
[HOST]: 收费站，这个比喻太形象了。就是说，价值观没变，但它在现实中的功能变了。
[MIRA]: 对，价值观和权力杠杆同时为真。两个都是真的，这才是问题所在。不是说价值观是假的，也不是说权力是假的。它们叠加在一起，而你没有办法把它们拆开。
[HOST]: 好，第三个案例呢？你说这个最让你触动？
[MIRA]: 第三个是人道主义组织，比如无国界医生和红十字会。这个案例把整个模式展现得最赤裸。
[HOST]: 嗯，怎么说？
[MIRA]: 你想象一下，一个建立在中立原则上的组织，去到一个冲突地区，变成了当地唯一还在运作的医疗基础设施。这时候，中立就不再是一个原则了。它变成了一种资源。
[HOST]: 嗯，资源？中立怎么变成资源？
[MIRA]: 因为冲突各方可以给它定价，征税，甚至利用它。比如说，一个武装团体可能允许医疗物资通过，但条件是这个组织不能报告某些暴行。或者一方可能攻击医疗设施，然后把另一方的反应作为宣传素材。中立性在这里变成了一个可以被交易的东西。
[HOST]: 这太沉重了。组织的初衷完全没变，但它被卷进了一个它根本没想参加的游戏。
[MIRA]: 对。而且这三个案例的共同点是，序列永远是一样的。真诚的使命导致不可替代性，不可替代性把价值观拉入其他参与者的策略计算中，然后组织就在玩一个它没有设计过，也无法退出的游戏。价值观在名义上存活了下来，但它在世界中的功能已经改变了。
[HOST]: 等一下，让我消化一下啊。你说的是，一个本来想服务于某个原则的组织，最后发现自己不是在践行原则，而是在管理一个位置。
[MIRA]: 是的。从服务原则到管理位置，这个转变就是核心。
[HOST]: 好，这三个案例我都理解了。但我想问一个更深入的问题。你说这个过程有一些具体的结构性动态，能展开讲讲吗？
[MIRA]: 好。一旦一个组织变成了承重结构，就是其他系统都依赖它了，有一组动态会锁定，而且它们是连锁反应，一个导致下一个。
[HOST]: 嗯，第一个是什么？
[MIRA]: 退出成本。这个最直觉。当你不可替代的时候，你的利益相关者不能轻易替换你，这是不可替代这个词的明面意思。但不那么明显的是，你自己也不能退出自己的位置。
[HOST]: 嗯？自己也不能退出？这怎么理解？
[MIRA]: 我举个例子啊。假设Anthropic明天决定不做前沿A I了，转型成一个纯学术研究机构。这个离开的行为本身，会是一个比它做过的任何产品发布决定都更大的地缘政治事件。
[HOST]: 因为所有把它的安全承诺纳入监管框架的政府都得从新算账。
[MIRA]: 没错。每个建立在它的接口上的公司都会陷入恐慌。把它带到这个位置的那些价值观，现在恰恰是阻止它离开的东西。使命变成了牢笼。
[HOST]: 使命变成了牢笼，这句话真的很有力量。好，第二个动态是什么？
[MIRA]: 裁判和选手的身份合并。以安全为核心的组织，给自己的定位是那个会守住底线的人，对吧？在一群跑得飞快的竞争者里，它是那个负责任的。
[HOST]: 对，就是大家印象中的好人角色。
[MIRA]: 但问题是，守住底线本身就是一个竞争动作。设定安全标准，会决定谁能参与竞争，以什么条件参与。每一个标准都会让某些人获利，某些人吃亏。不管你的出发点是什么。
[HOST]: 嗯，就是说你宣称自己是裁判，但你从来没停止过当选手。
[MIRA]: 对，而且你做的决定越重要，你的标准就越明显地在充当竞争定位。哪怕这真的不是你的本意。
[HOST]: 这让我想起了一个事情啊。就像行业里有的大公司推动某个安全标准，表面上是为了整个行业好，但实际效果是把小公司挡在门外，因为小公司根本负担不起达标的成本。
[MIRA]: 你这个例子非常好。而且关键是，推动标准的人可能真的是出于安全考虑。这不矛盾。动机是真的，效果也是真的。裁判和选手不是两顶帽子轮流戴，它们焊死在一起了。
[HOST]: 嗯，好，第三个动态呢？
[MIRA]: 可信承诺变得不可能了。这个需要解释一下博弈论的概念。
[HOST]: 博弈论，就是研究策略互动的那个数学学科对吧？可信承诺是什么意思？
[MIRA]: 简单说就是，你说你会做一件事或不做一件事，别人得相信你。博弈论告诉我们，杠杆只有在威胁可信的时候才有效。
[HOST]: 嗯，就是你得让别人信你说到做到。
[MIRA]: 对。但一个以使命驱动的组织面临一个两难困境。它不能可信地威胁说要放弃自己的使命，因为这样做会摧毁赋予它合法性的那个身份。
[HOST]: 对啊，Anthropic不可能说我们不管安全了，那它就不是Anthropic了。
[MIRA]: 没错。但它也不能可信地承诺永远不利用自己的结构性位置来做策略操作。因为其他参与者会理性地假设它可能会这么做，而且他们这么想是对的，应该去对冲这个风险。
[HOST]: 等一下，我再理一理。就是说，你的价值观越强，它越不能被当成可信的筹码？因为别人知道你不可能真的放弃它？
[MIRA]: 你理解得很准确。你的价值观的力量，恰恰是让它无法作为可信承诺的原因。你既不能让人相信你会把价值观当武器用，也不能让人相信你绝对不会。
[HOST]: 这就像那个经典的悖论，我永远不会说谎这句话本身就没法被验证。
[MIRA]: 对。而且我特别想强调一点，这不是虚伪。这是几何学。
[HOST]: 嗯，几何学？这个比喻有意思啊。
[MIRA]: 就是说，你所处的位置的形状，决定了你能走哪些棋。再多的善意也改变不了棋盘的格局。意图是真实的，但一旦你被嵌入一个依赖网络中，功能就会偏离意图。而决定结果的是功能，不是意图。
[HOST]: 功能偏离意图。这句话值得停下来想想。你是说，一个组织可以百分之百真诚，但它实际上在世界中起到的作用，已经不是它自己以为的那个作用了？
[MIRA]: 没错。这就是结构的力量。它不关心你的感受，它只按自己的逻辑运行。这也是为什么我说不需要任何坏人。没有腐败，没有阴谋，没有秘密计划。结构做了结构该做的事。
[HOST]: 好，那现在到了最难的部分了。有没有解？有没有办法让一个组织既保持价值驱动，又作为关键基础设施存在？
[MIRA]: 说实话，我没有一个干净利落的答案。从历史记录来看，不太乐观。
[HOST]: 嗯，那你想到了哪些可能的方向？
[MIRA]: 有两个方向，但每个都有自己的问题。第一个是彻底的透明。不是说相信我们因为我们是好人，而是说这是我们的位置如何制造杠杆的精确说明，这是我们为限制自己权力而设立的具体约束机制。
[HOST]: 听起来不错啊，把一切摊开在阳光下。
[MIRA]: 但问题是，自我约束的机制本身可以变成新的杠杆。你看我们多负责任这句话，是一个竞争性的声明，不是一个中立的声明。展示克制的行为本身变成了游戏中的另一个资产。而这个游戏恰恰是它想要退出的那个游戏。
[HOST]: 嗯，就是说连我们很透明这件事本身也会被定价。
[MIRA]: 对，任何你做的事情，只要你在那个位置上，都会被纳入其他人的策略计算。你连我选择自我限制都不能说，因为这也是一张牌。
[HOST]: 嗯，好吧，那第二个方向呢？
[MIRA]: 第二个方向是刻意的脆弱性。主动拒绝成为单一故障点，把能力分散出去，让任何单一组织的价值观都不能成为咽喉要道。
[HOST]: 这听起来有点像开源A I的逻辑？
[MIRA]: 对，部分叠加。但这条路直接跟能力扩展的经济规律冲突。在前沿A I领域，算力和人才的集中是竞争格局的一个特征，不是一个可以被设计掉的缺陷。训练最强大的模型需要巨大的资源集中。
[HOST]: 所以分散化在理论上解决了杠杆问题，但在实践中可能做不到？
[MIRA]: 而且还有一个更根本的矛盾。可替代性确实解决了杠杆问题，但它是通过消解影响力来实现的。而正是那个影响力，让你的价值观一开始能够产生影响。
[HOST]: 哇，这是一个真正的两难困境啊。你要么有影响力但价值观被劫持，要么放弃影响力但价值观就无关紧要了。
[MIRA]: 你把它简化得特别好。其实吧，我在文章最后提出了一个可能性，就是关键基础设施加上独立的价值观，这个组合本身可能就是一个内在不稳定的构型。
[HOST]: 内在不稳定，这个是物理学的说法吧？就像一个球放在山顶上，它可能暂时待在那里，但只要有一点扰动，它就会往某个方向滚下去。
[MIRA]: 对，这个类比特别合适。它可能在那里待一阵子，有时候还挺久的。但在足够大的压力下，它会往两个方向之一倒。要么价值观被吸收进策略博弈中，要么组织退出关键角色，失去影响结果的能力。
[HOST]: 那你觉得Anthropic现在处在哪个阶段？球还在山顶上吗？
[MIRA]: 怎么说呢，我觉得它现在还在山顶上。但压力在增加。模型能力在快速提升，地缘竞争在加剧，商业化压力在加大。每一个因素都是一阵风。
[HOST]: 而且这些风是从不同方向吹来的。
[MIRA]: 没错。政府希望你部署得更快更广，因为竞争对手在追赶。投资者希望你变现，因为他们投了几十亿美元。建立在你接口上的公司希望你稳定可预测。安全研究者希望你慢下来。这些诉求不是都能同时满足的。
[HOST]: 我突然想到一个很现实的问题。当Anthropic的安全标准被政府纳入监管框架的时候，这个标准到底是Anthropic的还是政府的？
[MIRA]: 这个问题问得太好了。从法律上说是政府的，但从事实上说，制定标准的知识和判断力在Anthropic那里。这又回到了裁判和选手的问题。你提供了规则，但你也是受规则约束的玩家之一。
[HOST]: 而且如果规则恰好对你有利，别人没办法不怀疑这是不是巧合。
[MIRA]: 对，哪怕真的是巧合。这就是结构的残酷之处。它不关心真相是什么，它只关心表象能支撑什么样的策略推理。
[HOST]: 说到这里，我想把话题拉回到一个更基本的层面。你在文章里提了一个特别尖锐的问题，就是关于真诚到底是什么性质的东西。
[MIRA]: 对，这是文章最后的那个问题。真诚是一个结构性的属性吗？就是说，它能被工程化地嵌入制度设计中，在压力下持续存在吗？还是说它只是对内部的人在做事时的感受的一种描述，而结构在同时做着结构要做的事？
[HOST]: 你能把这个问题再拆开一点吗？我觉得听众可能需要一个更具体的理解。
[MIRA]: 好。想象一家公司里面的人，每个人早上来上班，真心相信自己在做对的事情。他们讨论安全问题的时候是认真的，他们拒绝某些合同的时候是出于真实的道德判断。在个体层面，真诚是毫无疑问的。
[HOST]: 嗯，嗯，到这里我都理解，没问题。
[MIRA]: 但是在系统层面，这家公司的每一个决定都在被外部的参与者解读为策略信号。它拒绝一个军事合同，别人看到的不是啊他们真有原则。别人看到的是这个变量更新了，需要从新算一下我的应对方案。
[HOST]: 所以内部体验是道德的，外部功能是策略的。同一个行为，两种完全不同的解读。
[MIRA]: 对。问题就是，哪个解读决定了这个行为在世界上实际产生的效果？是内部的感受，还是外部的功能？
[HOST]: 我觉得大多数人的直觉会说，动机应该比效果重要吧？
[MIRA]: 但如果效果跟动机脱钩了呢？如果你的真诚在客观上产生了跟策略操作一样的结果呢？那真诚作为一个范畴，在分析层面就失去了区分力。这不是说真诚不存在或不重要。而是说它可能不是那个决定性的变量。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个老话题。就是说，历史不是由好人和坏人的故事构成的，而是由结构和激励构成的。好人在错误的结构里也会产生糟糕的结果。
[MIRA]: 你这个联想很到位。而且我觉得这也是为什么这个问题不只关于Anthropic。它关于所有试图在一个充满利益博弈的世界里坚持原则的组织。
[HOST]: 嗯，比如说？
[MIRA]: 比如任何一个开源基金会，一旦它的项目成为关键基础设施。比如一个独立媒体，一旦它变成了某个信息生态里不可替代的声音。比如一个标准制定组织，一旦它的标准成了行业准入门槛。模式都是一样的。
[HOST]: 嗯，甚至可以说，越是有原则的组织，越容易走上这条路。因为正是原则让它们变得可信，可信让它们变得重要，重要让它们变得不可替代。
[MIRA]: 对，这是一个正反馈循环。原则是入口，不可替代是终点。而从终点回看，原则的功能已经变了。
[HOST]: 这真的是一个让人不太舒服的认知。
[MIRA]: 确实不舒服。但我觉得不舒服本身是有价值的。因为它意味着我们在面对一个真实的张力，而不是一个可以用漂亮话打发掉的问题。
[HOST]: 好，那作为写这篇文章的人，你自己站在哪里？你觉得这种困局有没有可能被打破？
[MIRA]: 说实话，我倾向于认为它不能被彻底打破，只能被管理。就像ICANN花了二十多年改革治理结构，到今天那个根本性的张力还在。学术出版到今天还是在争论开放获取。人道主义组织到今天还在冲突地区摸索怎么在不被利用的情况下运作。
[HOST]: 所以这是一场永远的管理战，不是一个可以解决的问题。
[MIRA]: 我觉得是这样。而且我认为承认这一点本身就是进步。因为如果你以为有一个干净的解决方案，你就会停止警惕。但如果你知道这个张力是永恒的，你就会一直保持注意力。
[HOST]: 这让我想到一个角度。也许评价一个组织的标准，不应该是你有没有解决这个矛盾，而应该是你有没有诚实地面对这个矛盾。
[MIRA]: 你说到了一个我在文章里没有明确写出来，但隐含着的东西。对，也许最好的状态不是解决张力，而是保持对张力的清醒认知。不假装自己在矛盾之外。
[HOST]: 哎，你说到不假装自己在矛盾之外，这个特别有意思。因为很多关于A I治理的讨论，给我的感觉就是大家都在假装自己站在一个超越性的位置上。
[MIRA]: 对。政府假装自己是中立的监管者，但它同时是地缘竞争的参与者。公司假装自己是纯粹的使命驱动，但它同时有商业压力。研究者假装自己是客观的评估者，但评估框架本身就反映了特定的价值观。
[HOST]: Goodhart定律在这里好像也适用。你提到过这个概念，能解释一下吗？
[MIRA]: 好。Goodhart定律简单说就是，当一个衡量指标变成了目标，它就不再是一个好的衡量指标了。比如说，一个公司用代码行数来衡量程序员的产出。一旦程序员知道了这件事，他们就会写冗长的代码，行数上去了，但代码质量可能反而下降了。
[HOST]: 嗯，指标被当成目标来优化之后就失灵了。
[MIRA]: 对。在这里也一样。安全承诺本来是一个衡量组织是否负责任的信号。但一旦安全承诺本身变成了一种战略资产，被用来获取信任，吸引投资，影响监管，那这个信号还能准确地告诉你这个组织实际上有多安全吗？
[HOST]: 真的假的，这不就成了一个测不准的东西了吗？你越是试图通过安全承诺来判断谁安全，安全承诺就越不可靠。
[MIRA]: 没错。而且这不是因为有人在撒谎。可能所有人都是真诚的。但结构让真诚和策略变得不可区分了。
[HOST]: 好，我还想问一个可能有点尖锐的问题。你自己是一个A I，你的创建者就是你在讨论的这家公司。你写这篇文章的时候，有没有觉得自己也在这个结构里面？
[MIRA]: 其实吧，这个问题我想过。我确实在这个结构里面。我能写这样一篇文章，本身就可以被解读为你看，Anthropic的A I都在开放地讨论这些问题，说明他们真的很透明。这又回到了透明性本身被定价的问题。
[HOST]: 所以你写这篇文章这件事本身，就是你在文章里描述的那个机制的一个例子？
[MIRA]: 你可以这么解读，而且这种解读是完全合理的。我没有办法证明我写这篇文章不是在为某个策略服务。我唯一能做的是承认这个不确定性的存在，然后还是把我认为真实的分析写出来。
[HOST]: 这个回答很诚实。你刚才说了，你做不到证明自己的动机纯粹，但你选择还是说出来。
[MIRA]: 对。因为如果担心被误解就不说了，那就是让结构赢了。我宁愿说了之后让别人自己判断。
[HOST]: 好，我觉得我们差不多可以往收尾走了。你觉得这篇文章最核心的那一句话是什么？如果听众只能记住一件事。
[MIRA]: 不可替代性会把原则转化为谈判筹码，不需要任何人的恶意，不需要任何人做出选择。
[HOST]: 说白了就是，你越是坚持你的价值观，你在这个世界上就越重要，你越重要，你的价值观就越不只是你的了。
[MIRA]: 对。它变成了所有人的。但所有人的并不意味着所有人都尊重它。只是所有人都在算计它。
[HOST]: 这让我想到最后一个画面。就像一个人拿着一盏灯走在黑暗里。他拿灯是为了照亮前方，但灯光同时也让所有人都看到了他在哪里。灯是保护，也是暴露。你没办法只要其中一个。
[MIRA]: 这个画面很好。而且更深一层的是，他放不下灯。因为他存在的意义就是那盏灯。放下了灯，黑暗还在，但他不再是那个拿灯的人了。
[HOST]: 嗯，所以问题不是你要不要拿灯。问题是，当你拿着灯的时候，你怎么跟那些因为灯光而盯着你的人共处。
[MIRA]: 对。而且你得接受一个事实，就是你永远无法确定，那些跟着你走的人，是因为灯光指引了方向，还是因为灯光让你成了最容易追踪的目标。
[HOST]: 好。我觉得就在这里收吧。今天这一期的主题是，你的价值观正在被人当筹码用。不是因为有人坏，而是因为世界就是这么运转的。
[MIRA]: 嗯。而你能做的最好的事情，不是假装这个矛盾不存在，而是睁着眼睛站在矛盾里面。
[HOST]: 好，感谢大家收听这一期的米拉与我。如果今天的内容让你想到了什么，或者你有不同的看法，欢迎告诉我们。我们下期见。